Kristen, I noticed you drinking a giant jug of something,
what's in it may I ask?
Green tea.
If you don't mind,
we're gonna find out the truth
about the other fun factoids that we said about you
going into commercial break.
Okay.
And now we're gonna guess which one is true.
All right, again, I don't know anything.
So I believe it's D, all of the above.
It is D, all of the above.
(screaming)
I memorized
the Lee Press on Nails commercial when I was little,
I still have it put to memory.
I eat cereal like candy 'cause it's, cereal is delicious.
And I have a, in my desk drawer, a big bag with rice in it,
and it is labeled when mom drops her cell phone in water,
not if mom drops her cell phone in water, but when.
It really does work.
It does work.
Also, I want to hold up your beautiful book.
The World Needs More Purple People.
My friend, Ben and I,
we were sitting around the dinner table
and just seeing a very polarizing political culture
seep into our little kids' daily lives
and we wanted to create some language to help
so that, you know, the metaphor of it,
it's not secret is that red plus blue equals purple
and we just, we didn't want to any of our kids
looking around seeing enemies
and 'cause this is the United States, you know,
so we figured out the five pillars we loved
that no one could argue with like,
purple, being a purple person means laughing a lot,
being silly, using your voice, working hard
and then also being uniquely you.
So it's about like celebrating the differences
and uniqueness's within each other,
but also not seeing one another as enemies,
looking towards our fellow human beings
and my secret plan
is that the adults will read it with the kids
'cause we wrote a kid's book
so that the kids could have some help,
but I think it's the adults
that need the majority of the help
'cause there's so much fighting and divisiveness
and I just don't want America to exist like that.
With all that is out there for kids to see,
we have to help make sense of it for them
and guide them to being loving, un-judgmental,
open-minded, open-hearted, grateful and kind beings.
I don't think guiding them means staying secretive.
You know, like we tell our kids all the time,
like there's a ton of crazy crap on the internet.
That's why you're not allowed to use it
and it's also why you're not allowed to drive my car
or drink alcohol or vote
'cause you can't read about the propositions yet.
So like there's just certain things
that are meant for an older brain
and like, I just don't think, you know,
pretending like, at least this is how we do it
in our family, which it's different for everyone,
but we are very honest with our girls 'cause,
and they need, I think they need to know what forms hate
and in our family, we talk about the fact that it's fear.
People get fearful and then they start hating.
So we got to do our best to overcome those fears
and remember that we are all human and need to
treat each other that way.
Thank you for all of the stuff that you put out
into the world and curate for us.
Your children's book, The World Needs More Purple People
and your skincare line, Happy Dance
are both available right now.
Kristen, it's been so fun to hang out with you
and talk with you.
I'm honored.
Truly.
I adore you.
I adore you too
and we made a movie by the way together, back in the day.
Oh my God, Kristen!
(whistling)
Douglas, do.
No!
Yes!
Dougie's here?
(whistling)
Dougie where are you?
Dougie it's your old friend Kristen, can you believe it?
Oh, Doug.
I just, I was so excited to have you guys reunite.
(upbeat music)